you've kept a bit of a tight lid on who
you're backing in the nude ship race so
I was hoping that you might bear to tell
us this morning
what can I firstly pay tribute to Matt
Hancock who ran a really energetic and
vibrant campaign he was you talked about
international tensions he wanted to
invest up to 3% in defense he wanted to
harness technology to promote and
improve our economy and he wanted to
reform our party but that those messages
I'm afraid were suffocated by the
subject of a brexit so I do hope whoever
becomes Prime Minister will look at Matt
look at his talents to make sure that
they include him so did you vote for
Matt Hancock in the last round then well
of course
well of course we voted for Matt we
wanted Matt to move forward what we want
to do though is now recognize that Boris
seems to be the runaway winner and the
natural cause will be to move and
support him that rugby ball has popped
out of the scrum and he's grabbed it the
question is though do we just allow him
to walk across to the touchline and put
the ball down and have that coronation I
don't think that's right I actually want
to see Boris tested the nation is
watching this we should utilize this as
opportunity to showcase to road-test
policies show that we deserve to remain
in number 10 so I ask my colleagues to
say who will Electrify this contest who
will actually test price and get him to
raise his game who will actually allow
this to go beyond our base I believe
with Boris Johnson in one corner and
Rory Stewart in another that is a
competition that will be exciting so
bring that on so just to be clear you
voted from that hand Court last time and
now you're gonna switch and vote for
walrus to it this time round that's
great do you think Boris Johnson would
be a good Prime Minister I you look at
his policies of where we are he's
actually a center-right pragmatist he's
very much wanting to move Britain
forward there is this huge issue over
brexit that dominates and I think he
would make a fine Prime Minister my
concern is the fact that he may be
wanting to tilt towards no deal and that
is a big concern for me this will damage
our economy it would damage our
reputation internationally
and also damage our security prospects
as well with Rory Stewart we have
somebody who's committed to make sure we
leave with a deal and that's what I
would like to see so how far would you
go in order to prevents a No Deal if for
example Boris Johnson becomes Prime
Minister and the government policy
becomes to pursue a No Deal break so if
the negotiations fail would you vote
against the government in a confidence
motion well I'm wanting to pursues this
conversation now beyond our party base
to say absolutely we should avoid that I
don't think it's right to start
committing yourselves one way or another
we need to make the case to make the
argument to say we understand why no
deal seems to be attractive right now
running away from a situation that's
been you know we haven't found a
solution for the last three years but
that doesn't take us into a good place
it would actually see the breakup of the
Union it doesn't answer the Northern
Ireland question at all and it isn't
something that anybody really voted for
back in 2016 we need to be better than
that and I think that there is appetite
in the EU to say let's get a deal across
the line what's really interesting is
that every single candidate Rory Stewart
and Boris Johnson all of them have said
two things one let's unite the party
secondly let's resolve brexit if we can
get every one of those candidates
themselves to work together to say we
are committed to support the new prime
minister to get the deal we then have
the numbers to get this across the line
okay now I'm keen to move on and talk to
you you had a few issues with your
ministerial hat on because we've seen a
ratcheting up of tensions with Iran
haven't we with the attacks on those two
oils hankers and there are reports this
morning that Royal Marines being sent to
the Gulf to try and protect British
warships can you just tell us what's
happening there and are you worried
about a conflict with Iran
well these caches that are rising are a
concern for us all the Straits of muse
is a an active international passage for
oil and other commodities to come out
it's important that they are free that
they are able to move without the
problems or the challenges that we face
and when I visited the region I'm aware
that there's been a lot of skirmishes
that take place not on to the level that
we've seen in the
last few days but nevertheless tensions
are rising and let's not forget Iran has
a proxy influence a negative influence
in Syria in Bahrain in Iraq and indeed
in other countries as well and that is
causing extra tensions in the Middle
East itself I understand the
frustrations over the nuclear deal but
that does not give license to start
attacking ships in the Straits of Hormuz
so have Royal Marines been sent that
well this is operational decisions it's
for a penny more than the defense
secretary I'm sure we'll provide more
clarity of that next week we have a
substantial presence in the Middle East
that looks after our interest there we
understand the Middle East we have a
number of allies there as well we'll be
working with the United States to make
sure this area is safe and to make sure
that we actually de-escalate the
tensions there but I don't think around
should be under any any doubt the fact
that we orbit will be determined to
protect our assets and our interests in
the region and then just finally Sky
News has learned this week that there
was a Chinese company Chinese owned
company who's involved in the production
of circuit boards for f-35 warplanes
used by the UK and the US and of course
this comes off the back of concerns
around while way being involved in the
5g Network are you worried about the
involvement of Chinese companies and do
you think the UK government has been a
little bit naive I don't think we've
been naive this is a active question
that we need to decide how we use
intelligence who our friends are and how
we deal with a very very changing world
what we're seeing as a relationship with
a Huawei and its own nation its own
state China they operate on different
rules than we do and we need to make
sure that our core infrastructure assets
when it comes to 5g are protected and
are not vulnerable the scale of change
that our life will go through with the
rollout of 5g from communications to the
way we do business
it means the vulnerability will be there
and we need to be able to make sure that
we guarantee that safety and so there
are further questions to be asked I
think before the decision is made one
way or another